I've just come to understand that even organic meat can come from animals that have been
vaccinated, especially since they cannot use antibiotics.
Do you have any thoughts or recommendations on how we can all mitigate the damage coming
away from the recently publicized mRNA vaccines that are being used or are going to be used
in our animal products or even regular vaccine products that we are already eating in our
organic meat?
This is really a tough one because this is heartbreaking.
Now actually you could read that they're actually using mRNA technology and vaccinating
plants.
So some of the foods that you're buying even in old foods market are vaccinated.
If you look at Mercola's site, he's done some articles on this, some other people have
done some articles on this.
And they're problematic.
They think that they're doing the world a favor by putting mRNA vaccines in our plants,
in our animals.
It's very disheartening.
How do you get away from this?
The only way that I think that you can get away from this altogether is to be trying your
best to grow your own food, buy from local co-ops that you know and you trust the people
that are growing your food.
There are meat of livestock, cattle ranchers that are putting out there that they are not
ever vaccinating their animals.
I saw an Instagram video of a company that a cattle ranch that said we will never vaccinate
our animals.
You know, going on and on about how everything that they try to do is organic as possible and
they are very up front with their statements I did go to their website.
And unfortunately, you pay a whole lot more for the meat.
You know, I think it was, I can't remember now because it was a few weeks ago that my wife
said, hey, look up this cattle ranch because she shared an Instagram post with me and I looked
it up and it was like $12 a pound for hamburger, maybe it was even more than that.
So it was like, oh, any person, this is expensive, you know, when you're trying to feed your, you
know, when you have, you know, 15 to your grandkids coming over and, you know, another 10 adults,
it gets to be expensive, feeding everybody.
You know, you're raising a family, it can be extremely expensive to try to do things correct.
The, you know, we, you know, we needed my wife and I, we are huge gardeners, I've already
alluded to that.
Someday I'll share pictures of our garden, maybe next week I'll remember it takes a
picture, some chairs and pictures of our garden, and we're very proud of, but it's so
much work.
We just both love to do it and we do, of course, everything is organic.
We don't use anything, not organic on it.
And we do, yeah, we do it because we eat our own food, we share it with our children and
grandchildren, but we do it mainly to be honest because we love to do it.
I don't know when I was a little kid, I wanted to be a farmer.
So, you know, we put it in the sweet corn last year, that was 100% organic sweet corn from
Saudi seeds, shared it with our family, our grandkids literally just ate it right off the
stock without cooking it, it was so good that we put in a whole bunch more of this here.
But you still, I mean, we did it, can it, we froze a bunch of it, but literally my wife
and I finished everything that we froze within a month.
We tried to save two bags for Thanksgiving, but to produce enough food for a family, if you're
doing it yourself is very, very difficult throughout this whole COVID thing, you know, you hear
all this talk about people out, oh, we're just going to go buy a hundred acres and live
off the land.
Okay, most people have no idea how much work that is.
So maybe you guys do, but most people have no idea how much work that is years ago, my wife
and I, and then we had three kids at the time, we lived off the land.
We lived up on 270 acres of the middle of the woods on a river, completely off grid for
three and a half years.
And my sister and brother-in-law, the sister who works for a marine, lived there too then for
two and a half years of that time, and it is, I tell you, we were a lot younger than.
So it is very difficult down my wife and I do a lot of gardening.
My wife, Bailey, does the flowers I do, Bailey, the vegetables, and it is exhausting to try
to live off of everything that you make and grow and eat is, you know, for most people, it's
just not doable.
So how do you navigate this?
I don't know.
You can't even trust the organic stuff that you buy anymore.
Bottom line is you just have to do your best.
You just do the best that you possibly can and you have to trust Scott for the difference
because otherwise you'll go crazy.
So and I don't think that it is, it is reasonable to put that on yourself or on anybody that you
have to grow all your own food.
I just think this is the fate of what's going out of the world now and we're getting close
to the end and I just can't see how, how, how you population is going to navigate these
mRNA vaccines that are going our way.
So just do your best, try to do your best, that's all I could say.